hi sir I'm Robin got from bag Lulu and I
want to ask you a question sir that why
the people of India there they are
inspiring they're inspired to become
doctors ingenious but not scientists why
Sir and how can you inspire them to
become scientist there is really a need
of scientist in this world thank you sir
ok but there are very good scientist in
India I can satisfy and and so of course
you said there are so many physicians
many but how to promote the research
even more in India is by motivating
young people to science explaining that
the science is a beautiful adventure you
explore the the feel of knowledge you
discover very beautiful landscape and
sometimes you are got a five hour
application that are useful for the
humanity and so you you have to motivate
young students with the sort of
arguments and is what i am doing when
they are visiting I school in France or
in other countries